heads up guys my name is channel and
welcome to episode 117 of game
programming so last episode we make we
made the player name appear over here I
can we create a nice drop shadow effect
for our labels which was pretty cool but
today we're going to add the health bar
kind of thing that you see here is the
HP and it's got like a bar of health and
looks pretty cool so let's do that so
what we should do first of all is that a
new UI component for that kind of thing
so that will basically be what's called
a progress bar ok so if we go into
graphics you I will just make a new
class which is a UI progress bar so
every UI class always have the UI prefix
just to make everything of it easier so
this will extend the UI component and UI
component really doesn't have much it's
got a background color which I didn't
even know it had that's actually quite
weird oh it's got a color okay we can
get rid of background color I don't
think that's you saying that yeah it's
not so background colors kind of is
replaced with color which means
background color apart from a few
drawing texts in which case it means
foreground color anyway and really it's
only going so that and an offset but
that's offset gets set automatically it
does it set offset like I guess so I
don't know yeah I don't know why there's
a set offset as well because I guess
it's offset to UI panel so let's see
what this does
yeah you can see it sets the offset I
the offset doesn't strike me as
something that should actually be public
though let's change that so we can't
make it protected we can make it just
default
and we can get rid of all we have mad at
default we just made that yeah okay well
in that case we'll make it private cool
oh sorry protected okay a lot of
warnings most of these are just unused
things though let's actually just
quickly clean up some of these warnings
because I want to know if we actually
have any general generally legit
compiler whines I think we do though
types aren't used here apparently
whatever will make it protect it and
that'll fix that warning because who
knows it might be used in the future um
okay
collections never used yeah so we'll
clean up a lot of these imports fonts
never used yeah why did why did we have
a font there we shouldn't have had a
font there that was alpha testing code I
think shoot closest is never used I
don't remember what that was for I'll
keep that in there shooter I think sure
it was our guy probably what time and
level we'll keep that we might use that
in the future for like day/night cycles
which we should probably get around to
doing soon because I really want to do
that um life for the particles born I
never used cuz just passed long yeah
give that them and annum for player yeah
we don't need that alright cool so clean
up a bit of this which is good let's
just basically close everything is that
for you why progress bar so let's make a
case of what do we need right we
definitely need a size and this size
isn't going to be like the progress
clearly the size is just going to be the
general size of it so if you look at
this the size would be the size of the
entire thing no matter what progression
we're up to so we do new size so let's
see
so we've got a size when you just taking
a size this size equal size
public/private stuff below I think
public first public int progress so this
will be 0 to 100 always in fact I'll
make it private because I want I want a
method which sets it correctly if we
were if we were really cool we could do
something like if progress lesson zero
or progress greater than 100 were new
like our range exception where we have
here range exception yeah we could do
some like that in fact I might actually
do that we had I think we've ever ever
throw exceptions before I hate
exceptions but they might sometimes to
be good because well in this case it
it'll literally stop actually like crash
the program and we can be like ok this
is the point at which we've done
something wrong
what is this I'll carry a stirring
messages so way at one string message
throat will calls
yeah what are the constructors we have
for this just string message yeah it's
pretty good
Dwight why does it open a runtime
exception if I want a range exception
well this is lovely
what is going on Java range exception
short code what is the code what's the
code I don't know 0 whatever message
progress must be between 0 numbered so
can you take me to that for right
intercession I get code
are we are bad boundary invalid node
type um if the boundary points arranged
yeah I guess we'll do this I don't know
this is incredibly formal and
unnecessary but whatever so we've done
that that's probably the first bit of
good coherent
not that I would actually encourage
exceptions ever but anyway I mean
they're not the worst
they're the worst in C++ they're not
they're fine in managed languages but
but still I I'm not the biggest fan of
exceptions so progress cast this is what
we want so we set the progress so that's
why I made it a setter for it by the way
and not just public because I actually
want to validate the data and since we
made a setter I'm and private we should
also get a progress okay I now come the
actually good things so what am I
looking for
where's that button thing generate no
where are you delegate methods yeah it's
not what I wanted
what am I looking for I'm looking for
that thing to override methods where's
that at
it has to be here right overriding from
the message that's what I don't know why
it took me someone to find it and so
render an update okay that's just
because I was a bit lazy to type these
update and yeah I think we need much for
that but renders gonna be a bit
interesting because it's gonna be kind
of similar to rendering a panel so if I
open up UI panel we can see we kind of
set the collar and we just feel react
thing what kind of noted same thing you
know I said the color what we actually
do want to do though is we want
foreground color it's pink and public
void set for rounds
color okay and put that the reason we do
that is because we set the car and we
feel this stuff in and that's fine and
it is actually a component so if we go
into UI label we do wanted to have the
plus offset stuff okay and then the size
should be correct so if we just run this
right now it should just display like a
bar kind of thing so I go to play it
real quick and let's just say we have a
private to UI progress bar UI health bar
I'll pretty much prefix everything with
UI I think so panel dot add component UI
health bar which will set equal to
whoops a new UI progress bar so the
position which is what's relative that
to that other thing probably be around
about our name except below it so name
will drop it to like 240 maybe now the
size will probably be on the Y around 40
and then maybe like gee I don't know
like 350 or something I'm guessing I'm
not glue
and if we just render that so that's
that should be rendering now okay cool
so we need to make that a little smaller
I also don't want it to be offset that
much so like and maybe ten to forty
seems a bit trials right because the
bottom is to ten will be fine because
the bottom is the other thing yet so
let's see over here let's just try like
250 how big that Aubry be 150 okay and
we're definitely on 140 very fat 180
yeah that's pretty good
maybe to 15 to 10 how big is this panel
by the way eighty times three isn't it
so let's set it to eighty times three
minus twenty that should be perfect and
it is fantastic see how good masses okay
so let's keep hitting the volume wheel
on my keyboard all the views for that
okay so UI health bar dot set color this
is the background color so it looks like
we want to set it to like so essentially
a very slightly lighter gray than our
background so whatever that background
there it is so we'll probably just
increase this to like five F or
something don't know how that's gonna
work out that's pretty good it might be
a bit maybe you like 6a or something
oops just so we can distinguish it
better yeah it's pretty good we don't
really care about it too much because
the progress is was going to be honest
so we do want to set hello
let's not get too excited we do want to
set the the red component pretty high so
that's probably going to be quiet yeah
so it's looks like just too dark imagine
that so we'll probably just set it to
like that ish I don't know what that
looks like yet oh I do well I'm setting
the color yeah that's Mel it's pretty
good to me yeah it's actually a bit more
subtle so let's do this yeah yeah a bit
more okay that's going to be good enough
I like yeah what color is like if I
really wanted to I could just color pick
it but I think that's probably all right
okay cool
so anyway we want this to be the
foreground color so anyway back in this
in this land why we ever rode up there
we probably don't need that but it's not
like it's gonna have animation in mice I
know we'll decide yeah so what we're
going to do is we want to set the color
here to our foreground color and we want
to basically render everything at that
thing but this is where it becomes the
size this is where the size will kind of
change so this is zero so the size X is
actually going to be zero that's kind of
it doesn't have an offset it's just zero
right except what it's actually going to
be is the progress now the progress of
course is between 0 and 100 so yeah I
mean it has to be the progress has to be
I'm actually kind of regretting making
this a probably should've made it like a
float or something because we're gonna
have to divide it by a hundred that was
a terrible idea wasn't it
or maybe not actually but really the
progress should just be multiplied by
our size except that's not really gonna
work in this case but that's kind of
what we want to do so let's make this a
flirt otherwise it's going to absolutely
destroy me if I just make it a double
so as to be between zero and one that's
my Believix way to do this because that
that way will work for whatever size
obviously it's going to be so double and
then where's that set progress all right
this is typically how these things would
work by the way so now that we've done
that we can basically be like what's the
progress times without maximum sizes
which is X okay and then that's totally
work because obviously when progress is
going to be one we're going to be at our
maximum size which is well like not in
our two hundred and something that's
right we set it to like a math
mathematical thing mathematical thing
which is really like 220 I think yeah so
that's 220 but um anyway when this one
is gonna be 220 ones there's gonna be
zeros come just work out really well so
that being said let's call this tourney
and make sure you cast that result to an
int not like you don't put brackets
around it's just gonna cost progress to
an int which will be an absolute
disaster because always going to be zero
so for them when it's 1 make sure you do
both
ok cool anyway now that we've done that
look at the foreground color so that
should be an int
okay now that we've done all this let's
launch this and see nothing which is the
correct result so let's go over here
into like update or whatever and we can
be like UI health bar they'll set
progress 0.5 half good 0.20 flight and
one yeah pretty pretty cool so now that
looks pretty good and if we really
wanted to we could even do like a bit of
an animation thing so in time equals
zero sign mod time plus blast mod 100
divided by 100
and suddenly record a progress bar
animation alright but there you go so
you can see that totally works well and
that's beautiful so we've got a progress
bar now one thing we are missing though
is and we don't actually have real
health so let's just make this like
health which will make in a minute sorry
well actually probably set it to health
/ oh let's just say the player can have
a maximum of 100 health or something so
we'll make it health / 100 point zero
and help will be an integer so all mobs
will have health
the player will start with like a
hundred or something obviously wrong
constructor this is Mike that's
advocated so that we don't so that we
can just remind ourselves that you
really shouldn't do anything with it
okay cool so that should be a full
health by now great so um
last thing we need to do here they're
all we're done and this is yeah okay
last thing we need to do before we're
done is display just HP in white letters
so let's do that so the reason one thing
I want to mention quickly is I am copy
I'm pretty much copying another Mac God
directly just for the sake of having
like a target I guess just having
something that we want to achieve right
having like a target to achieve because
if I'm I love how activate Windows is in
the screen show that's fantastic
anyway um if I'm making this stuff on
the spot you guys might think that I'm
trying to avoid doing some hard things
or that I'm kind of making it easy or
something so the easiest way is to take
an existing product and try and
replicate it because that way it'll
teach you everything you need to make a
game similar to run with a bad god and
that was the entire point of this series
so anyway that's why I'm doing this
strictly because you can basically see
that oh okay
if I follow this series I can make realm
of the mad God so that's that's our idea
anyway HP so let's do that let's go into
so that'll be a separate label obviously
yeah we don't need to we actually need
to do that we can just add and all the
add components so UI label
so position will be basically this
offset by a little bit so plus in fact
if I want to be really nice like I just
say UI UI UI health bar dot position dot
add except that's going to really clone
it say that I wish I would return a new
does that return on you and that
probably doesn't returns this yeah we
don't want that
okay well here's what we can do I think
my harp if it doesn't let it but you
should be able to go in use vectors to I
the white opposition don't add like true
icon to the add to part that can you do
this yes you can fantastic so we can
create a new constructor good now let's
add a let's add an add that just takes
in an int value and just adds it to both
x and y okay and our text is just HP hit
points or health points or well it's
traditionally its hip hit points but we
could just write health if we want to be
a bit different from Rome mad dog but
whatever so dot we don't want to drop
shadow we do want the color to be so we
can use set color if we just want to set
it to an integer which I find is usually
easier and then we will also set the
font right
so vadhana seems to be pretty good seems
to be working out pretty well so far
font a plane and sighs yeah this is
gonna be difficult
I'm gonna say like 18 but we'll probably
have to do a lot of experimentation
together to fit properly let's just see
what happens here nothing that's great
let's maybe at the right label okay so
that's us right that's the bottom so
position dot this isn't gonna work cuz I
thought I was the top left why is the
font from the bottom left that's so
weird Java what are you doing so let's
add a new vector 2i so we'll add
apparently like what's the height like
20
we might add like 18 and then yeah like
sorry 18 to this and to that is what I
meant that actually looks that actually
fits really well I'm just going to keep
the fond 18 I think because that font
seems to work it it seems to work out
very well there we go
OHP done let's take a look at what that
looks like when the our health is not oh
whoops that's not that shooting
yeah let's probably not put it an object
shooting let's put into update i'm
actually making new method for it but
anyway this seemed pretty good so let's
set the pearl set the health to like 50
the zero yeah so it works on pretty much
all kind of surfaces as it would expect
it to
so yeah yeah pretty good so there you go
looks pretty good and yeah if you wanted
to you could probably change it to and
where is this am I looking for
he'll write if you just want to just
play help I don't know that looks a bit
kind of yeah I think HP's probably a bit
more subtle it doesn't bounce in the ice
so much but yeah there you go so hope
you guys enjoyed this episode of game
programming where we added a new UI
component called progress bars next time
we'll probably add but at our mana
points and fame or something I don't
know we probably need to decide what
this games going to actually look like
if you guys are up for it if you guys
want to take maybe I don't know if you
guys are okay with next episode maybe
taking a break from actual programming
for the first time in the game
programming series and just doing a bit
of a planning episode in fact I might
live stream it if you guys are
interested in that I might live stream
just basically a planning episode and
then put it up on YouTube or what does
not put it up on you should at all as an
episode of game programming just so that
so just so that we all have some ideas
about how this games going to work
because as you can see we're actually
getting into game design now that we
have a lot of stuff working very well
and of course I don't want to make this
game exactly like rather than that god I
just want it to be capable of
replicating it all back up anyway if you
guys enjoy this episode please the like
button let me know what you think about
that idea and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
you